- [Instructor] In other videos
we talk about some of the
truly ancient Chinese
dynasties, the Shang Dynasty,
the Zhou Dynasty, and as we
get to the end of the Zhou
Dynasty, China falls into
chaos in the Warring States
Period, which is a really
tough time for China.
But the silver lining is it's
also the time that you have
all these schools of
thought, the Hundred Schools
of Thought, of which
Confucianism and Daoism
and Legalism and all of these
other schools of thought
begin to emerge.
But what we're really going
to focus on in this video
is the beginning of truly
imperial China under the Qin
Dynasty from which China gets its name.
So here we are in the third
century B.C.E. and you have
your first true emperor
of China, Qin Shi Huang,
and the dynasty that he
sets up is known as the Qin
Dynasty which will be
shortly lived but it's known
as the first dynasty to truly unify China.
This is where we believe the
word China actually comes from,
from the Qin Dynasty.
The dynasty is known for its
fairly harsh, centralized
rule motivated over the
foundation on legalism.
In terms of relics that
we have from that period,
you might have heard
of the Terra Cotta Army
which was buried along
with Qin Shi Huang's grave.
Now the Qin Dynasty is
most known for ending the
Warring States Period and
unifying China, and really
laying the foundation for
the Golden Age of China
that will happen in the Han Dynasty.
The Han Dynasty lasts from
roughly 200 B.C.E. to a little
after 200 C.E.
And in my head I think of
it as bit of a contemporary
as the Roman Empire.
The 200 years of the Western
Han Dynasty correspond
roughly to the Roman
Republic, and as we get to the
Eastern Han Dynasty, that
corresponds to really the heyday
of the Roman Empire.
And it's also a golden age of
China, a time where science
and the arts, and especially
Confucianism begins to
really take hold in China,
becomes officially part
of the civil service,
part of the bureaucracy.
The Han Dynasty was so
successful at unifying China
culturally and linguistically,
that today, 92% of Chinese
identify themselves as ethnically Han.
So sometimes you'll hear
the word Han referring to
the Han Dynasty, and sometimes
it will be referring to
the Han ethnic group,
which really derives from
the notion of the unification
under the Han Dynasty.
Now the Han Dynasty, as we see
here, ends at the beginning
of the third century in the
Common Era, and then China
gets fragmented again,
and it gets split into
multiple dynasties.
This roughly 360 years that
I don't have marked on my
timeline, it's not that
nothing was happening in China,
in fact, a lot was, but
China was not unified.
To get a sense of that,
here is China during the
Three Kingdoms Period
in the third century,
shortly after the fall of the Han Dynasty.
You see the Jin Dynasty depicted
here in the fourth century,
still part of what's often known as the
Six Dynasties Period, this
roughly 360 years of a
fragmented China.
And then you see this North
and South Dynasty Period
here in the sixth century.
And eventually, China is
reunified, and that happens
under the Sui.
It is unified under
Emperor Wen of Sui for whom
the dynasty is known,
and similar to the Qin,
what the Sui are most known
for is taking this chaotic
period and finally unifying China.
And the Sui are ethnically Han,
and they lay the foundation
for another golden age
of China under the Tang
and the Sung Dynasties.
The Tang Dynasty depicted
here, it rivals the Han
as a golden age of China.
It's a time where the arts,
the sciences really come about.
One interesting thing about
this Six Dynasties Period
that we talk about,
which is a chaotic time,
it is a time that Buddhism
starts to come into China
from central Asia, originally
from India, and by the
Sui and the Tang, it really takes hold.
Now one of the most important
innovations that comes from
Tang China is the notion
of block printing.
What you see depicted here
is one of the first books
ever printed, the Diamond
Sutra, during the Tang Dynasty.
Now, after the Tang falls in
907, you have, on a historical
time scale, a relatively
brief period of chaos again.
About 50, I guess exactly
53 years where you get this
Five Dynasties and 10 Kingdoms
Period, but then China
gets reunified under the Song Dynasty.
And the Song Dynasty is able
to, on some level, pick up
where the Tang Dynasty left off.
One thing that happens as
we get into the late Tang
Dynasty, is that there's
push-back against Buddhism
that we talk about in
other videos, and you see
Neo-Confucianism begin to
take hold and it really
takes hold under the Song
Dynasty that we talk about
in other videos.
The Song Dynasty is also
known as a time of really
putting a lot of energy
into the civil service
and the bureaucracy, and it
really being very meritocratic,
based on some of these
Neo-Confucian ideals.
It's also a time of significant
technological innovation.
The compass, which has use
as early as the Han Dynasty,
but it really gets into its
fairly evolved or modern form,
especially for maritime use,
during the Song Dynasty.
The notion of a Chinese
junk boat also gets into its
evolved form during the Song Dynasty.
Some of the really far-reaching
innovations from this
Dynasty include building on
the Tang use of block printing,
but thinking about movable
type, which makes printing
far more practical.
And maybe the biggest single
innovation that changed
the world, for better or worse,
was the use of gunpowder,
which there's some use in
the late Tang, but it really
starts to get perfected
during the Song Dynasty.
The Song Dynasty is
eventually overthrown in the
13th century by the Mongols.
They are able to establish
the Yuan Dynasty with
Kublai Khan being the first emperor of it,
grandson of Genghis, or Jen-gees Khan.
They are eventually
overthrown in the 14th century
by the Ming Dynasty.
The Ming Dynasty is once
again ethnically Han,
and some of the most famous
attractions that are associated
with China today really came
about from the Ming Dynasty.
This is the Forbidden Palace,
the imperial residence
during the Ming and Qing
Dynasties in Beijing.
This is the Great Wall of China.
And even though the history
of the Great Wall of China
goes a good ways back, even
to the Zhou and Warring States
Periods, much of what you
now see as the Great Wall,
a lot of this brick work, was
built during the Ming Dynasty.
And then the last true
Dynasty of China is the Qing.
The Qing Dynasty is again,
to some degree, foreign rule.
It's ruled by the Manchus
who come from Manchuria,
which is this region right
over here, and they're
eventually able to
overwhelm the Ming Dynasty,
and ruled China all the way
until the early 20th century
when the Republic of China
is able to overthrow them.